moi je peux vous assurer que monsieur
benallal n'a pas exercé de missions de
police
il ya différentes missions fonctions à
coordonner dans un déplacement
la relation avec les élus la relation
avec la presse les enjeux de
communication les jeudis collée à
l'intérieur de chacun de ces domaines y
compris la sécurité il peut y avoir
plusieurs services de sécurité qui sont
concernés de ce point de vue là il peut
y avoir une mission de coordination de
la sécurité mais en revanche ils
n'assurent pas la sécurité du président
en fait je paquet de l'ambiguïté
d'ambiguïté là dessus le deuxième volet
de sa mission de ses prérogatives
c'était l'organisation des déplacements
non-officiel du président de république
alexandre benalla on avait ne commandait
pas de service n'avait pas d'hommes sous
ses ordres
il n'avait donc pas les moyens ni
hiérarchique ni fonctionnel d'exercer
une quelconque forme d'autorité en tant
que chef adjoint de cabinet monsieur ben
alors exprimé les souhaits et les
demandes de la présidence de la
république
la confusion des rôles la confusion des
missions l'ambiguïté en tout cas des
fonctions de monsieur benalla et des
gens qui l'entourent dans ce dossier
nous nous pose de graves problèmes
sur notamment la lisibilité des
instructions qui pourrait avoir à donner
à nos collaborateurs
[Musique]
j'ai considéré là aussi dans ma
responsabilité de directeur de cabinet
en charge de la sécurité de chef de
l'état qu'il pouvait être utile dans ces
circonstances de déplacements privés
qu'il y ait dans l'entourage du
président la république
une personne qui est un port d'armes
mais qui est habilité à la voir qui a la
formation pour la voir moi je peux vous
assurer que monsieur benalla n'a pas
exercé de missions de police
d'abord est-ce qu ils sont de baignade à
porter son arme dans le cadre de ses
missions à l'extérieur
personnellement moi je ne les ai jamais
vus j'ai indiqué que vous aviez dit l'
inverse lors de votre audition devant la
commission denquête de l'assemblée le 25
juillet dernier à 9h30 du matin puisque
vous avez indiquée
commençons par monsieur benalla je n'ai
vu porter une arme bien sûr dans le
cadre de certaines de ses missions
oui j'ai vu alexandre reynal à porter
une arme je ne veux bien sûr je ne renie
pas ce que j'ai dit aux auditions ce qui
me revient c'est que j'ai vu également
porter son arme au retour d'une séance
de tirs
parce que ce jour-là il m'avait il me
l'avait montré plus physiquement si je
puis dire